trying to let's start it tonight today
we announced
a 500 million dollar Landmark lawsuit
against the Memphis Police Department in
the city of Memphis
for the
torture
Savage
brutal
dehumanizing
extrajudicial killing
of Tyree Nichols
this Landmark lawsuit
is not only
to get the justice
for Terry Nichols in the Civil courts
but it is also
a message
that is being sent
to cities all across America
who have these police
oppression units
that
have been given the license
by city leaders
to go and terrorize
black and brown communities
whether they be in Atlanta Georgia or
whether they be in New Orleans Louisiana
or Chicago Illinois or Miami Florida
these jump out units these Red Dog units
these proactive police units these Brave
units
these scorpion units that we're going to
talk about in particular many of us in
the black community
know them as the jump out boys
many of our white brothers and sisters
have never heard of the jump out boys
but the jump out boys are known far too
often in Black communities as police
officers Jennifer who are given license
to harass and brutalize black people
and brown people
and this lawsuit and the amount that
we're suing for is a message that if you
keep
giving license
to these
gang minded police officers
to
perpetrate acts of terrorism
on
black and brown people
then we're coming to your city
and we're going to bring these lawsuits
in every city where there is a George
Floyd that is
savagely killed
at the hands of law enforcement
where there is a Avo
otieno
savagely killed at the hands of law
enforcement where there's a Tyree
Nichols savagely killed at the hands of
law enforcement
if it happens in your city we're coming
to your city too because
let me be clear and unambiguous about it
it is our mission
to make it
financially unsustainable
for these police oppression units
to unjustly kill black people
in the future
we want to make them where they can't
even afford it where they're going to
train their officers differently where
they're going to get rid of these units
because they're going to say we don't
want what happened in Memphis Tennessee
with Tyree Nichols to happen to my city
that is what rovonne talks about when
she talks about the legacy of Tyree
Nichols it's not just about getting
Justice for him but it's also about
preventing
any of the families
having to looking at hospital bed
and see their child
projecting the image
that
immaterial projected 70 years ago
The Savage beaten of Tyree Nichols was a
direct and foreseeable product
of the unconstitutional policies
practices customs and decisions made by
the city of Memphis
attorney ramanucci is about to address
you in just a few minutes
and you will see this Landmark lawsuit
goes into great detail
about
how from the top down
that this was for syllable
because this were
the policies and the procedures
of the Memphis Police Department
how does this horrific and
unconstitutional treatment of black
women
and women
by law enforcement continued to happen
Tyrese condition in the hospital
can be likened to that
of Emmett Till 70 years ago
who was also beaten unrecognizably
by a Lynch Mob
but Tyrese Lynch Mob
was dressed in Department issued
sweatshirts and vests
sanctioned by the entities that ran the
Memphis Police Department
please Memphis
please America
we must hold
each and everybody
accountable who had any hand
in the torture
the savagery the brutality
the extra judicial killing of Tyree
Nichols each and every one of them must
be held accountable
if we are to create meaningful change
once and fall
please Memphis please America
let us not have to see it take 70 years
to hold people accountable
to the point where we won't see any more
of our children
looking like Emmett Till
and if we don't hold all of them
responsible
from the top to the bottom
shame on us
if it happens to your child
shame on all of us
finally it's not lost on me Kareem Ali
that
it was 55 years ago in this city
that Martin Luther King was assassinated
and that's why
we are intentional about bringing this
lawsuit for 550 million dollars
we're trying to send a clear message to
Memphis
in a clear message to America that's
right
that's right no more Tyree Nichols
no more Tyree Nichols no more no more
Tyree Nichols no more Tyree Nichols no
more Tyree Nichols
no more Tyree Nichols
and before attorney ramanucci coming to
dress you Dr King said this
the law
can't
make a man love me
but the law can keep a man from lynching
me
and he said that's a pretty important
thing
he said
that the law
cannot change a man's heart
but the law can restrain the heartless
and he said this is why we say
we must have legislation
policies and accountability
to be able
to deal with the evil
and the injustices of the world
today
we are sending a message
that in tari's name in Tyrese Legacy
we're going to have meaningful
legislation
and meaningful accountability
to the point where we will not have any
other individuals killed in the manner
that Tyree Nichols was killed
that is the assignment that Miss Revan
talks about with such conviction
will you join us in this assignment
and now you will hear from a great
lawyer
an extraordinary lawyer
a person cut from the same vein
of the Thurgood Marshalls and the
constant Baker motleys
uh lordy who steeped in civil rights who
believe in civil rights for all of our
citizens we fought together for George
Floyd and now we're fighting together
for Tyree Nichols
I consider my brother and I'm so honored
to try
to push the turntables of History
together to make a better world for all
our children
and that is attorney Antonio raminucci
from Chicago Illinois
thank you very much Ben and of course
thank you rovonne and Rodney for this
honor of representing your son Tyree
Nichols in this horrible tragedy I do
want to give special thanks to the
remainder of the legal team
ravani Bryce Sarah Dave Brooke thank you
so much for for all that you've done
so I'm here to talk a little bit more
about the lawsuit and why it's Landmark
because today for those of you who are
here you are at the beginning of the
witness of History
this lawsuit is Landmark not only for
the monetary compensation that will be
awarded in this case
but it's because of the depth and the
breath
of the indifference that we saw on
January 7th
but you have to understand one thing
Tyree died
much longer than before he sustained
that Savage beating on January 7th
the decision-making process that went
into what the Scorpion unit did on
January 7th happened
months and years earlier than that
because of the deliberate indifference
of the chief of police of this city
Sarah Lynn Davis
she put that scorpion unit in place
because she thought that because you put
the word peace
you embed peace within scorpion that you
were going to get peace but instead that
scorpion unit was a stinger and they
only had one mission
and we know what that mission was and
we're going to call it out right now
stop young black men in cars and get
whatever evidence you can from those
vehicles and suppress it
that's what scorpion was all about the
same thing that red dog was all about in
Atlanta Georgia when they tried to run
every drug dealer out of Georgia with
red dog
Sterling Davis brought the concept here
put it on a different name
so what did we witness instead the
three-headed monster
the three-headed monster of the city of
Memphis
the individual officers
and the paramedics
all in some sort of explicit or implicit
conspiracy to let this young man die
they killed him and they let him die
nobody cared about him each one of those
three-headed monsters was indifferent
and is indifferent to this day because
as we know of nothing's changed except
scorpion unit is disbanded what other
policies have changed since then to cure
the indifference that we have and I know
of none so this this this lawsuit this
lawsuit is Landmark because of those
reasons we are going to peel back every
single onion layer that we can to expose
the indifference that's been existing in
the Memphis Police Department not for
days not for weeks but for months and
when they were told when this community
told Memphis police in December December
6th of 2022 that scorpion unit was
acting unconstitutionally
Tyree had a chance to be saved that's
right but instead those pleased by you
all were ignored that's right and
instead what happened there's a sign up
above me I am a man
with dignity
Tyree had dignity all the way to the
very end and we can't say that about
anybody from the city of Memphis it's
police officers its Chief or even its
paramedics the unfathomable task of
saving a life and they ignored this
young man's pleas when he cried out for
Mom three times
it's just unimaginable incomprehensible
that is why ladies and gentlemen this is
Landmark there this is there are many
prongs to this lawsuit and we will show
you why it is Landmark because of the
depth and breadth of this indifference
they beat him
they ignored him
they mocked him
they took pictures of him
unless we not forget
they lied
they lied who did they look to
mom yep
they lied to Mom and you will see that
in the lawsuit there's a count or counts
for intentional infliction of emotional
distress
because Lieutenant Smith
went to go see robon and Rodney
not didn't lie once didn't lie twice
I wish I could say three times
but the entire conversation was a lie of
Deceit
when her son was yards away trying to
call for Mom
being denied
this family these parents being denied
the opportunity to see him because they
were told lies about him
that's why this is a landmark case
that's why we will make history that's
why our goal Ben team our goal is to
make systemic institutional widespread
change Memphis and in the country thank
you so much
thank you so much attorney ramanucci and
now we will hear from a pillar in the
legal Community here in Memphis
Tennessee a mentor of mine and I'm so
proud that we get to work on this
historic case together a retired judge
Ernestine dors will now address you
a great great
woman lawyer and everything in between
and I am a person of brevity
and I just want to make it known and
place you on notice that we're not here
Mrs Wells is not here
for vengeance
we're here for accountability
accountability
and so when
Tyree asked what did I do wrong or what
did I do
you now notice on
there should be an answer to the
question of what will you do
what will the country do
what will we do
so that those questions won't have to be
asked under the same circumstances and
that everybody should be on notice that
there's always a Payday
and I am not talking about a Vengeance
not necessarily the 500 000 I mean the
500 million
but we still have to pay but what it is
that we do on this Earth
so it's not a Vengeance thing it's an
accountability thing and so step up to
the plate and answer the question
you'll notice what will we do
or what will you do amen
thank you judge
and the final uh two people you will
hear from
are the people who knew Tyree best
uh
they've been so
dignified and graceful in their grieving
and they're here again to continue to
talk about
uh the assignment
and then we will try to take some of
your questions uh we give you
uh
uh Rodney Wells Tyrese father and
tyree's mother rovonne Wells who as you
all know Time Magazine has named
time 100 most influential people in the
world
and she is somebody who continues
to rivet us
as she talks about
her assignment that God has placed on
her child's life Miss rovonne Wales and
Mr Rodney Wales
[Applause]
first of all I want to thank everybody
for being here today
500 million
that's a lot of money
but just as the judge spoke
this has nothing to do with the monetary
value of this loss of lawsuit
but everything with that has to do with
accountability amen those five police
officers murdered my son
they beat him to death
and they need to be held accountable
along with everyone else that has
something to do with my son's murder
I never thought in a million years that
I would be in this place standing here
but I can tell you this
as I've said before
my son was here on an assignment
and he's fulfilled that assignment God
took him home but now it's my turn
to make sure that my son's death does
not go in vain
and we have to
do some things push
push push some issues in order so that
this will not happen to another child
because I tell you
this shouldn't happen to no mother no
parent no parent should be going through
what I'm going through right now I don't
wish on my worst enemy
but things need to change I've met some
beautiful people in the last 90 days
but
I've met him under these circumstances
because now we're all in the same
fraternity and those beautiful people
that I'm speaking of are the moms of
Ahmad Arbury or Brianna Taylor or
Trayvon Martin's mother
those people are beautiful people but
see what happened we're all now in this
fraternity that none of us want to be in
we've all lost our child due to some
type of police violence and this just
needs to stop I mean how many more
Tyrese
is this going to happen to we we just
can't have this
thank you thank you
I just want to say thank everybody for
coming out
I want to thank our legal team Tony
rominucci van Crump
uh and Kareem Ali especially
um my wife was pretty much said
everything that I could ever say under
these circumstances
uh this is a landmark case it will make
history
and I just thank everybody for being a
part of this
as my wife said about joining this
fraternity we had no idea we did not
want this
we would trade places with anybody
you know people think this is glamorous
it's not
you know we go home at night we cry we
weep
um
our lives have to change dramatically
because of this
we were simple people we like to come
home
after work watching sports
and go to bed
I've just been turned upside down
so
as I said my wife has pretty much said
anything or everything that I wanted to
say so thank you very much
keep them focused on the legal matters
and directed towards the attorneys thank
you thank you Jennifer McGuffin
um I'll say this in anticipation of your
questions the lawsuit is going to be
electronically disseminated to ending
everybody who wants it
um
and bhavani and Bryce I understand
there's
897 paragraphs of this lawsuit
and Sarah and Brooke and everybody who
worked on this lawsuit
understands that every paragraph in this
lawsuit speaks to the brutality
of this Lynch Mob that were cloaked
with a gun and a badge assigned by the
Memphis Police Department
and their actions and why we must hold
them accountable every word in this
lawsuit
every punctuation mark in this lawsuit
was
Jermaine to where
robon just said
accountability
that's what Tony Roman Nucci Ernestine
Doris and I tried to spell out in this
lawsuit painstakingly we went back to in
Atlanta in 2006 when the 92 year old
grandmother was killed by the Red Dog
unit because it was foreseeable right
attorney ramanucci it was for a syllable
that if you have these types of police
oppression units
people will be brutalized
people constitutional rights will be
violated
and worst of all
innocent people
like Tyree Nichols would die
and so we'll take your questions
certainly I'll talk about the mountain I
have attorney ramonucci go through the
names
um
but as
we thought about this
attorney ramanucci uh attorney Doris
Kareem and all of us
we were intentional with the 550 million
dollar amount we're seeking
we wanted it to not only speak to the
conduct of these officers but also to
the policy for which these officers were
following
and we wanted to send a message to other
cities
that have similar policies
that say it's okay to terrorize
black people in Black communities and in
brown communities
and so it was intentional
we it wasn't a mistake when we say 550
million dollars this is the 55th year
of the anniversary
of the assassination of Martin Luther
King and we're in the city where Dr King
was assassinated
so this is a landmark lawsuit for a
myriad of reasons the dollar figure
being just one of them attorney
ramonucci will talk to you about
everybody who we sued in this lawsuit
attorney ramanucci thank you
so I I think what's critically important
here and I will tell you exactly who we
have sued and under what theories
but this is one of the first times that
we know
that unconstitutional violations were
given as an order in this city for the
Scorpion unit to carry out
when Chief Davis told her scorpion unit
get the cars don't worry if the case is
dropped in court that is a
constitutional edict
an unconstitutional edict excuse me
and then when you have the officers on
the scene
who talk about make sure you stomp his
ass
look at what happens when you marry
those two policies together you're going
to get needless harm unnecessary death
and you're going to get this
so those people are all accountable
and who are those people
we're going to start from the top
it's Chief Sarah Lynn Davis
number one accountable liable
next
we have Emmett Martin
we have Demetrius Haley Justin Smith
Desmond Hills and to Darius bean and
those are the five officers who are
responsible for the individual beating
of Tyree underneath that pole camera
Chief Davis is being sued in her
official capacity as the policy maker
here in Memphis Tennessee
we have sued Preston Hemphill
he is the officer who has been astutely
pointed out he was one of the jump out
boys who held the gun and pointed it at
Tyree without even knowing if Tyree had
even committed a crime they stopped the
vehicle with no Reasonable articulable
Suspicion meaning they had no reason to
do what they do because Tyree was not a
suspect in any crime nor had he
committed one continued violations of
the law and then you have
the paramedics who are Robert long Joe
Michael Sandridge and Michelle Whitaker
who rather than check the ABCs
right that's what you're supposed to do
as a paramedic check Airway breathing
circulation
they let him sit for 19 minutes
while he lay there dying
lastly we have sued Dwayne Smith yes
who was the lieutenant who went to the
wells in Rovan home Rodney and rovan's
home and lied to them
so that is who we have sued in this case
what I want to tell you one more thing
Ben said there are 897 paragraphs I want
you to take a look at page four there's
a photo on page four look at the picture
on the left side
that is the picture of a young healthy
happy young man
I asked the people that we've sued to
make sure they look on that page also to
see what they've caused yeah
now it's an important question I've
often been asked at what makes this a
landmark lawsuit and the first answer
that comes to me in an attorney
Mendelson we're going to see
in the near future these officers are
going to admit
that this is how they were trained
they're going to admit that what they
were doing
was what they always did this was not
something unique and what makes it
unique in a landmark lawsuit is the fact
that this is going to be the first time
in America where they're going to hear
police officers saying no no we weren't
just uh bad apples that we were not just
somebody uh out for Saturday night kicks
to beat up somebody this is what they
trained us to do to young black men
and that is going to be landmark in the
astonishing nature of it but also it's
going to be Landmark for what attorney
ramanucci and uh all these great lawyers
are going to uh talk about as
establishing monel claim that this was
the pattern the practice and the policy
of the Memphis Police Department and
Memphis is not alone in this
that's what really is Landmark about it
because it is a warning sign to all
these other cities who are out here
terrorizing black people in Black
communities and brown people in the
communities because they think they have
a license to do it where we want them to
know if you do this
then we're coming to your city next
emergency
thank you thanks everyone should you
have any further questions Ben at Press
bencrump.com thank you very much and
thank you for being here